[Music]
I'm sadirah Hungary and I'm the product
manager for language AI here in cloudy I
I'd like to welcome here and thank you
for taking the time to talk about the
latest developments in translate and
natural language AI fun fact ml in there
until until this morning because of
yesterday's announcements so that's so
what we're going to be spending most of
our session on why are we here today
it's a quick agenda on what I'll be
covering as part of today's session so
the first part I'm going to talk about
natural language and our natural
language in cloud translation and dive
deeper and give you an overview of
translate following that we have two
customer case studies to customer use
cases on both auto ml natural language
and auto ml translate we have guest
speakers from Qualtrics and we localize
one of the largest localization vendors
in the US and towards the end of the
session I'll also provide some useful
resources so finally we can talk about
auto ml translation and auto ml natural
language we've we spend months working
on these new products and new
capabilities in cloud translation and
natural language let's do a quick deep
dark cloud translation is one was one of
her first forays into AI and api's and
this has been one loved API since 2011
we support hundreds of languages from
Africans to Zulu and using combinations
we support translations between
thousands of language pairs and with
neural machine translation announced
last year Google has been a leader in
this field you can translate text and in
case you do not know what the text
language is we also provide the
capability to detect the language of
the input tax is part of the transplant
translate API and I'm sure you're all
familiar with with it now with our
latest products that we've launched we
want to make it easier for every
business to solve their problems using
AI typically some of the problems in ai
ai is is hard it requires a lot of
machine learning expertise it can be
complex time intensive it requires data
science expertise to do hyper parameter
tuning machine learning expertise to
evaluate and understand what precision
is what recall is and finally you'll
have to spend time and effort to
maintain those models to deploy those
models and then keep them updated as you
scale we with cloud auto ml we want to
enable citizen data scientists to
customize and build your own machine
learning models in four simple steps and
what these simple steps are upload your
training data create your machine
learning model by training it and within
a matter of three to four hours you can
get a working machine learning model
customized to your company's use case
and the quality is expected to be much
better than some of the generic API so
generic translation models or natural
language models that you've seen before
so how distraught amel translate work
imagine you have a custom domain use
case you have Technol technical manuals
or possibly support related use cases or
oil and gas documents that need to be
translated you could use Google's cloud
translation API but if you have high
quality training data high quality human
translated language pairs that you can
provide a sample data into auto ml what
we do is with asses as little as 10
examples or 100
examples of a player very translated
language pairs you can train an auto ml
translate model and the typical training
model training time is about three to
four hours so within a matter of hours
you can get a translated model that can
work really well for technical manuals
or any custom use case that is that has
a lot of jargon or industry specific
jargon that a regular translate API may
not be able to catch I can walk you into
some of the example use cases where
custom or domain translation becomes
really important I lose the error
message here as an example device driver
is not working so you have the summary
of this is the drivers not working now
if I were to generate a translation of
this this string or this sentence
without providing any context to a
translate API this may mean a golf club
is not working in another context it may
mean that drivers on a strike and the
driver is not working and finally the
use case that we actually want to point
in another context in the context that
we actually want to point our machine
learning model to the device driver in a
technical context the software driver is
not working I can point here to two more
examples and more real-world examples
where one of our customers we localized
who's going to come and see shortly to
talk about their use cases we train to
machine learning models one for
restaurant reviews and the other was an
educational use case
so we localize build and machine
translated model
don't translate model and English to
German model for classifying restaurant
reviews and the English to Spanish model
on blackboard is corresponding to
educational or legal use cases and
here's a quick sneak peek into what the
UI looks like as you can see sentence
pairs are uploaded as training data a
model has been trained so this is a chip
that would keep rolling so you'd be able
to see it if it's too tough to catch at
first shot
so before I the comparison as well so
these are the uploaded sentence pairs
that are provided as training data the
blue score that is the level of accuracy
the bilingual language evaluation under
study which is used to indicate how good
of a model is the training output and
once you go to the predict step as you
can see that's a restaurant review the
service was nice and friendly is the
same but the drink prices were lifted
was as the drink drink prices are
upscale now upscale is a better and more
nuanced ran straight through translation
that applies to a restaurant review
there's another example that can be seen
in the predict stage we highly recommend
it versus we can only recommend this so
these are some of the nuance is that a
custom machine translated model will be
able to catch provided enough training
data let me walk you through another
example which is a Spanish to English
model and this has been trained on
blackboard again as you can see you are
able to view the blue score and that's
the predict step this was an educational
use case so the training data
corresponds to a lot of educational
jargon
and in the predict stage as you can see
graders versus qualifiers so the
qualifiers the [ __ ] the custom Google
the custom model versus the Google
machine learning model we see that
qualifiers is not very specific to an
education use case but graders is a
better translation with that I would
like to invite we localize Olga and Alex
who's who's been one of our alpha
customers hi everyone so I'm Olga
Raghava I manage language services that
we localize and managing machine
translation out will localize is one of
my responsibilities and Alex here senior
manager of machine translation and NLP
we localize ok so we'll continue and I
lost the clicker I swear it was just
here we'll continue on the subject of
customization and how important it is
for our industry maybe a couple of words
about our company we're the fourth
largest global content services provider
in America and seventh in the world you
can see some stats about our company and
using machine translation is essential
for our industry because we're after two
things we are after translator
efficiency and we are after being able
to provide raw machine translation
services customized machine translation
services for all customers so here are
the industries that we service and we
trained or m/l translate models for all
of these industries but we're going to
talk about examples from just two of the
industries so education as we said
earlier look at examples that we have we
have moderator FAQ converted from
frequently asked questions by the
moderator obviously that's a much easier
content to consume we have created
mashups which is our customer
proprietary terminology
and we have deadlines for national
submissions which is a corrected
mistranslation now next one would be
translation for open table now this one
we're not sure if we're going to be post
editing it or we're not going to be post
editing it so to make this decision
basically we don't know yet I will post
editing or not but what we do know is
that we want the most accurate
translation possible so what we have
here regional and national products is
it accurate or not we actually prefer
super original products now the next one
the service was very pleasant nice and
gorgeous extremely pleasant gives you
much better sense of sentiment and the
next one we can only recommend this and
we will definitely be back soon compared
to highly recommend and again you
capture much better sentiment drink
prices were lifted compared to drink
prices were upscale again you have
accuracy of translation here and the
next two sentences are just not accurate
happy to return compared to gladly again
and highly recommend compared to can
only recommend here again you're
basically dealing with the actual
mistranslation
okay so Olga actually spoke about very
specific sentences what I wanted to talk
about is how we would actually implement
this more in a programmatic way right
because often we don't have the luxury
of looking at individual sentences and
we need to forecast an entire program so
the way we do this is one of the
numerous auto scoring algorithms the one
that we use primarily for forecasting a
program and forecasting kind of time to
market and discounts is called P
distance which stands for post-editing
distance and what you see here on the
chart is three languages for a client in
the IT domain and you can see that the
what you're going for is the lowest
number so post-edit distance means the
number of change
at a character level to get from the
machine translation output to what you
consider your human your gold output
right so the idea is the less changes
you have to make as a translator the
more productive you are right the faster
you are the faster you are the faster
you can translate and therefore the
faster the product can get to market
that's one important thing also the
faster you are and the more productive
you are the more of a discount you can
give to a localization service provider
like us which we in turn can pass on to
the client right so what you're looking
here for is the lower the number the
better what's really really encouraging
here are a couple of things number one
so the dark red you can see that's
Google Auto ml translation that's the
lowest number so that's the winner
and the best P distance for the three
languages presented right and you could
see for French that that number compared
to second place the difference is three
percent right in the case of Russian
it's also three percent so you'll see
another example where it's even more
drastic so one takeaway is Google Auto
ml translation wins
what's also curious is second place is
Google Cloud translation so Google Cloud
translation is already very good and
Google Auto and now translation is even
better and has those lexical choices
that Olga mentioned the last thing that
I want to point out is you have six
contenders here but you'll see that for
Russian there are only four contenders
that's actually not a mistake that's on
purpose and the reason for that is two
of the contenders two of the competitors
that we looked at simply didn't even
have this language to score in the first
place so that's kind of another reason
why we found Google automail translation
to be so powerful the rich coverage of
languages that some other competitors
simply don't have it all so let's took
let's take a look at another case so
this is also IT domain for another
client another fortune 1000 client and
so what we often do is we look at auto
scoring which is very cheap and
efficient to do but we
also measure human evaluation so we'll
take we'll take some sentences as a
sample and we'll have a human being look
at them and adjudicate them based on a
level from 1 to 5 right scale of 1 to 5
with 1 as the worst 5 is the best right
and the idea here is we want to see to
what degree this lines up with the
patterns that we're seeing from auto
scoring right and here again you see a
similar situation so what we're looking
for is usability on a scale from 1 to 5
usability means to what degree are the
sentences understandable and actionable
and there are two use cases for them for
this one is you might want to do just
raw machine translation as Olga was
mentioning with opentable so it's gonna
come out with raw machine translation
that's it
it's not gonna be post edited at all so
we need to figure out how good this is
because no one's gonna touch it the
other scenario is post editing so we're
going to post edit this up to a human
level and again the better the initial
quality is the less we have to post edit
the more productive we are and the more
discounts we can give right so what we
have here is a table that shows a
hundred sentences that were evaluated in
these various competitors right on a
scale from one to five it's an aggregate
score and what you'll see across the
board for all of the languages is that
Google Auto ml came in first sorry so in
this case five here number one means
that it finished in first place meaning
it got the most fives so sorry about
that so we it was on a scale from one to
five but but these are basically ranked
you know number what go girl automatic
translation is the best and number six
here is actually the worst performer so
so I'm sorry if that was confusing so
the things that I want to mention here
is that you see that Google Auto ml
translation came in was the best in all
of the languages and you see languages
here that span Romance languages like
Spanish and French which are relatively
easy grammatically to kind of mid tier
languages more complicated grammatically
like German and Russian and finally
Asian languages like Korea and
and simplify Chinese which are
particularly difficult and and where
we've seen the greatest improvements on
neural and again the other thing here is
that Google Cloud translation came in of
the six languages it came in number two
twice and number three three three times
so again we kind of see this picture of
Google Cloud is very good to start out
with but when we train it Google Auto ml
translation clearly comes out on top and
this actually dovetails very well again
with the post editing distance for these
six languages so here the gray bar again
we're looking for lower is better right
because less edits that you have to do
so the gray bar the one that's lowest
for everything is again Google Auto ml
translation and you could see when you
look at second place often second place
is green which is Google Cloud
translation and the other ones are far
far worse right and you could see that
the difference between the gray and the
green is already fairly significant so
again we're seeing this picture of very
very good quality when we train Auto ml
translation and as Sudhir said we can
basically get these models back in 3-4
hours and start benchmarking and rolling
them out into production immediately
about the distance as I said earlier if
in case of open table we don't know if
we're going to be post editing or not
going to be post editing in case of
blackboard for instance we do know for a
fact that we are going to be both
editing and edit distance is our core
decision-making factor when we know how
we're going to be negotiating with our
client and how well going to be
negotiating with our translators so
basically knowing what we get for edit
distance is the way that we're basically
going to be that's the way we're going
to be structuring our business
conversations on both sides of the
equation this is why it's the key metric
for us thank you very much
[Applause]
thanks Alex and Olga moving on I'd like
to take you into a product walkthrough
of cloud national language API and then
dive deeper into Auto am a natural
language one of our newest product
offerings cloud natural language API
that's currently in GA currently
supports four different features and the
extraction as you'd like to extract some
keywords or phrases from from a text
passage sentiment analysis how positive
or negatively biased a certain article
is what's the sentiment of say a user
review analyzed syntax say you'd like to
get into the linguistic details or the
parts of speech of a certain text
passage what's in now and what's an
adjective so on and so forth and finally
classifying content our current content
classification API available within
cloud national language API supports 700
different categories and subcategories
and this is based on a predefined
taxonomy this taxonomy this content
classification API is trained on massive
volumes of Google data and it's highly
suitable for various categories but what
we've had our customers ask us is to
customize these categories to their own
use cases imagine an oil and gas
customer or a healthcare customer or
certain again technical data where these
classifications or labels or categories
are very custom to an enterprise use
case user reviews customer feedback may
need to be classified to let's say be
there is a flight survey experience that
that needs to be categorized into
ambience and service or food so on and
so forth so these categories may be very
relevant and specific to a certain
enterprise use cases a certain domain
and there may be use cases where you can
squeeze more accuracy out of
content classification API so that's one
of the primary factors for us diving
deeper into auto ml natural language and
the first feature that we've enabled as
part of auto ml natural language is
custom content classification now how
does this work again similar to auto ml
translation customers can come in to
auto ml with some amount of training
data we require at least 10 labor 10
examples per label for as a minimum
requirement for for running the model
and about hundred examples for each
label that's a very little amount of
training data that needs to be provided
to train an auto ml natural language
content classification model now once
this classifier is trained and again
this is going to only take about four to
five hours of training on some amount of
training data and boom you get your
custom classifier that is that's that
works specifically on your data your
data is not shared with Google or with
any other customer model or data and the
model can start to scale as needed
assume your model gets very popular if
you start seeing a huge amount of
requests the model can scale to adapt to
your custom demands and if you have
further amount of training data you can
always retrain your model and then the
custom classifier skills to adapt to
your needs and your own labels in
categories so how could you use or MLL
here's three examples you could predict
the tags of a stack overflow questions
say this is a very technical example
that the custom content classifier or
regular classifier api's may not be able
to catch you could predict which news
house a certain article is from and
healthcare assume doctors knows of
patients notes need to be analyzed again
90% of enterprise data is unstructured
so given an input of healthcare specific
terms
you could provide the model some
training data to tag symptoms to certain
diseases and the auto classifier can
start predicting based on this custom
used case behind the scenes what do we
do again - if you if you know throughout
this experience we did not talk about
hyper parameter tuning we did not talk
about anything other than just training
your data clicking on train looking at
evaluation metrics if you if the model
is good great then if the model isn't
you provide more training data or tweak
the model to your specific use case and
then you run predictions behind the
scenes we mimic a data scientist what
the data science would do to generate
the best model for your use case we kick
off multiple pipelines multiple google
google models and we surface the best
model for that specific customer data
set it's it's abstracted from the
customer which which parameters need to
be tuned which model to be used we we do
all the heavy lifting behind the scenes
and you see the best model that gives
you the highest precision recall for
your use case we've seen a lot of
customer excitement for auto ml we've
been in alpha for a while and we've had
a lot of customers one of whom is going
to talk in in in a brief while Qualtrics
but we've seen Meredith specifically on
national language hers Singapore
Airlines there's a lot of customers
within the new segment and various other
domains that have found significant use
cases within auto ml natural language
and within translate as well we see we
localize and plenty of other customers
with that I would love to go into some
of the details that Qualtrics can talk
about they've used all ml national
language for optimizing their survey
responses and loved formal in to explain
how to done that thanks to the Euro so
hi everyone my name is millon I had
product for Qualtrics surveys
you know our survey flies its flagship
product and what I'll do is I'll talk
about the problem that the the survey
research industry is facing we'll talk
about the solution and then we'll look
at you know under the hood how we
implemented that solution we'll also
show you some cool demos so with that
what's the what's the problem you're
trying to solve so you know at call
tricks we get every year you know we
reach there are more than 200 million
plus surveys you know we have billions
of survey responses and the problem is
that you know and this is just across
the survey research industry in fact you
would see better numbers here but you
know 85% or more of surveys are just not
completed I'm sure you can all relate to
that you know who loves taking surveys
and there's a reason why that's the case
more often than not the questions that
people ask in surveys are just plain
wrong they are not relevant questions
they are not worded correctly and often
that means that it results in invalid
data first of all you'd be lucky if
people would complete the survey and
even if they do you know the famous
saying write garbage in garbage out say
if you ask a wrong question you are
gonna get a wrong answer and that is
that's a huge problem it's resulting in
you know invalid data would be wrong
business decisions which is costing the
survey recent industry as much as four
billion dollars in losses every year
more importantly wrong business
decisions means you know to quote a
phrase it's sinking the ship for a lot
of businesses now what's the solution
for this well the solution is pretty
simple just create better service make
sure that you ask the right questions if
you are designing a survey make sure
that the questions you ask are very
relevant are very you know at Caltex you
call it predictive questioning and I'll
show you you know a demo of that and if
you're a survey taker let's make sure
that you are having an engaging
experience let's make sure you know I
think Sudhir I mention about post-flight
surveys
let's make sure that if you're getting
off a flight in and get a survey and if
you say that look I'm upset that the
flight was messy let's not ask a
question like on a scale of one to five
how happy are you you clearly you're
upset
you think you better ask a more relevant
question to that so you know you know a
quick show of hands how many of you
let's in the last one year I had a bad
time taking a flight so pretty much all
of us you all had the stories of having
a you know poor flight experience
sometime on the other the thing is you
probably don't know but a lot of flight
companies I'm a lot of them are our
customers they do take it seriously and
they do want to do something about it
they have armies of people who are
working on customer service working on
during to fix these problems but the
problem is you know they're doing all
the right things they're trying to get
feedback but they're not asking the
right questions so while they have
armies of people on standby to fix these
issues they're not able to find out what
is the issue that you know you as you
walk out of the flight had with the
flight you just took so here you know
what I'll do is I'll show you a quick
demo where we took a regular flight
survey we view it will be very familiar
you know you all must have enough from
your favorite flight and you got off
you've got a survey and you answer
questions we will show you an example of
what happens when we start introducing
AI when you started using auto ml into a
call tricks flight survey so with that
this is a video and let me just go ahead
and play
I'm sorry
uh-huh you just cut off your flight and
we ask your question so every question
how they fly and in this in this example
what will happen is we know that you do
not have any specific intent you do not
have any specific topical you want to
talk about so we will just you know in
the survey right there
however contrast that word if I say
something like how would apply if I say
if I'm really upset
maybe I'm just because I lost my bag say
you lost
now in this case we know that he'll me
you're not happy and secondly we also
thanks to the guys know what
specifically you're not happy about so
we will a knowledge that the person is
unhappy this come from the and an API is
that variable to understand the
sentiment in real time
but more importantly we also need to
understand what is that specific topic
customer has in mind and we asked
contention question on the specific
topic in this case it's our package so
we asked them a more specific question
on alright it tell me more about the
package piece as you can see here by
engaging in the customer on a more
contextual at a moment action feels much
more human-like much more conversational
and that has resulted in a higher
engagement with customers in surveys and
therefore a higher completion rate and a
higher quality
all right so with that second let's try
any more the next slide here I guess I
need to
oh I think I'm in today
it's seen it's all the tab up there so
I'm not sure you good they're escaping
at the time oh there you go
alright you know we should ask a survey
about this experience can you go back to
the slang so go back a few slides so you
know actually that's a good segue to now
so this was the the experience that we
could enable where as you can see it was
much more engaging we were you know much
more to the point the questions that we
asked were much more relevant and let's
take a look under the hood on how we
made that happen
so you know I think I said you
dimensional and how the technology works
what we did was we took a few of these
responses for one of our customers you
know when people give feedback after a
flight and we started labeling them
right we labeled them with a certain
purpose in mind so you know this company
did have a team working on flight
cleanliness so if somebody said that the
flights were you know the flights or
Messier flights were not clean we
labeled it as a cleanliness issue if
somebody said in the flights you know
talked about their that the prices were
too expensive or the flight was
unaffordable and so on we label that as
a pricing issue because there is a team
without that a customer has who works on
pricing so we firstly you know even
label a bunch of responses after that we
trained the model on those very
responses and it did a pretty good job
it are a pretty high precision and
recall and we also tested that but by
you know checking how good it is in
predicting what is the issue what is the
category when so many types a response
so you know in this case summary you
know this is a response that someone
said you asking me to pay for even the
smallest things which would at one point
free in a flight well all I am a little
pretty good job of saying well this is a
pricing issue so in a real survey it
would mean that this would get routed to
the pricing Department in the flight
company and now once the
was done we used call tricks to do to
help make a great survey so for example
we have this product expert review what
it does is it will be able to predict
what is the right question you if you're
creating a survey what's the right
question you should be asking and guides
you on how to ask that question so it
used the results of our demo to guide
people the survey creator and what's the
right question to ask we also have
functionality to how logic so we said
all right look if this customer starts
talking if first of all if he's unhappy
then ask a certain set of questions if
he's happy ask a different set of
questions if they're talking about in
this case service then ask questions
around how to improve your service so we
made sure that the logic in the survey
was super contextual and the net-net of
it was the demo you just saw where you
know in a in a flight like survey it's a
much more it's a very different
experience than what you would regularly
experience it's much more contextual
much a shot a survey much more to the
point let me wrap it up with one last
example and this time I'm hoping the
video comes out right so let's play this
video so this is an example you know
before I play the video of an e-commerce
site so you know we also a lot of
e-commerce companies and you know what
happens in e-commerce we all been there
we all go to an e-commerce site we all
go and shop but you don't buy just right
there right we we browse we take our
time you may ask you know a significant
other
eventually we go back and we decide on
one particular product to buy and what
ecommerce companies are trying to do is
how can they make that experience better
for their customers so how can they make
sure that you know the products they
show the selection is right how can they
make sure that the checkout experience
is very seamless right so they want to
get feedback and they use us to get that
feedback but let's see how even there we
can ask the right questions when you try
to collect feedback so for example if
somebody's saying that look I wasn't
able to find the right selection of
products let's
feedback about that let's not ask them
questions which are totally irrelevant
to what they're trying to give feedback
on so in this example this is a survey
that you would have with call tricks you
know and here they ask how was the
in-store experience and it seems like
they're not happy and we asked them why
were you not happy right and they say
the service was great but the checkout
was the poor experience so now we use
that returns to the order ml topics we
ask a much more pointed question we ask
them all right tell me more about
checkout and I'd not service not product
selection we get straight to the point
ask them specifically about that issue
and the survey is shot it's sweet it's
to the point and net-net it's a much
more engaging experience and you get the
answers which you know can help you make
decisions so yep that's how we use all
their mail and call tricks to create
engaging service thank you thanks Ben
it is confusing so we somehow Ottoman
our language empowered Qualtrics to
build more intelligence service both it
to ask good questions as well as to
consolidate the feedback from those
surveys and analyze those surveys and
feed that into and get that feedback
loop going that creates a virtuous cycle
of data-driven decision making this has
also Ottoman Asha language has also been
helping a lot of customers in the newest
domain Hearst Newspapers for instance
let me tell you a little example about
how hers in use auto ml natural language
to build our own custom classifier news
organizations typically have a large
repository of ephemeral content as well
as evergreen content by evergreen
content I mean articles that can be
resurfaced over and over again to
customers that have a lot these articles
have a longer shelf life and they can be
fed into recommendation engines they can
be used to personalize and increase the
engagement of of these websites so horse
build a custom classifier and again
ephemeral content versus evergreen
content if you were to tag news articles
with these two labels any regular
classifier would not have these labels
in the first place for you to go ahead
and build on top of this this would
require a lot of manual manual model
building process so within a matter of a
couple of days or hours in our AML
analyst kiss Hirsch was able to load
some amount of training data provide
certain articles that were manually
picked and tagged by their editors as
ephemeral content versus editorial
evergreen content and with that custom
classifier model that they got and
natural language typically takes about
four to five hours based on our internal
tests so after four to five hours of
training of training the custom
classifier model was able to predict
with accuracy in in the high 90s whether
an article was ephemeral or whether it
was evergreen now hearse is able to use
that and they're ready to deploy this
model into production to start to build
recommendation engines on top of on top
of this model they're also trying to
optimize using auto ml NL the foundation
that they've built with the OEM L and L
custom classifier model to in to improve
their ad systems so that's the power of
auto ml natural language a simple
process of building a custom classifier
can provide huge cost savings automate
physical processes and enable enable use
cases that weren't possible before to
quickly summarize if there was one key
takeaway from this session on both Odom
and natural language as well as our ml
translate high accuracy customization
and easy to use machine learning models
the these are the key key value
proposition that we would like to would
like to summarize the REM Ln L and or ml
translate products with if if there are
any further questions I'm happy to take
any take Q&A right after this session
we'll be right outside there's also a
couple of t-shirts I would like to give
away but thank you so much for your time
today there are more resources here
cloud translate the landing pages this
documentation is also some getting
started tutorials and quick starts
available for your use thank you
[Applause]
[Music]